The drinking bird is starting to look sort of vaguely like the real thing if you
squint a lot. Modifying this model a bit more, I made the legs white. When I do
this and run the program, this causes what is called Z-fighting as you can see
here. What is happening is the two polygons, one from the foot and one from the
leg are overlapping attempting to occupy exactly the same location. At one
pixel, one surface's Z depth will be infinitesimally closer than the other due
to precision limits. At the next pixel over the situation maybe reversed. While
this is fine mathematically, it can't happen in the real world and curling makes
for unconvincing images. Examine the problem yourself by running the program.
Find the link in the additional materials. The question to you is, which of
these solutions will fix the problem? Make each leg a bit thinner so it doesn't
overlap with the foot. Use a newer GPU with a higher-precision z-buffer. Switch
to another rendering algorithm, such as ray tracing. Remove the bottom part of
each leg so that no part of the leg and foot overlap. I should not that two of
these answers are correct.